you ever considered that all this is
your fault your presence creates these
animals
batman arkham city is the explosive
follow up to batman arkham asylum for us
at Rocksteady we really wanted to create
a sequel of it was interlinked with
arkham asylum in a lot of different ways
so just narrative lee in terms of
Batman's abilities is it's lovely
dovetailing between the two experiences
the action is taken out of the asylum
and onto the streets of Gotham City this
time round into an open-world structure
so as Batman you can deliver justice on
the streets of Gotham in a way that I
think a lot of Batman fans and gamers
are really going to love some of the
things that I think were taken on board
from the development of Arkham Asylum
was you know a couple of things I think
the boss fights could have had more love
put into more effort put in them and
that's exactly what we've done in the
development of Arkham City also the use
of detective mode as well was probably a
little exploited because the information
that you've got from the game world
winning detective mode in Arkham Asylum
kind of outweighed what you got in the
normal default mode so it made sense
from a gameplay perspective to stay in
detective mode we've rebalanced that
information that you that you garner
within those different modes in Arkham
City so I think games are going to
finally use it more as a tool they need
to achieve an objective they switch
detective mode on they get that
information and they switch it off and
carry on
I think it's natural to want to break
the rules every now and then so we
introduced Catwoman is a playable
character just to give players an
opportunity to take a break from being
the Caped Crusader every now and then
and walk on the wild side a little bit I
mean I'm not saying that you abandon the
city the chaos in injustice I'm not
saying that but playing as Catwoman
using stealth using thieving tactics
indulging that dark side was really
something we thought players are going
to like that change of pace so that's
why we've included her but she's an
integral part of the full but batman
arkham city experience and her and
Batman's tales kind of intertwined right
throughout the game the situation of
batman faces going into Arkham City is
that you know what's he going to do when
he gets his hands on to face because
these guys are already in prison he's
not going to arrest them and take them
somewhere else the the chaos and carnage
that takes place within the walls of
Arkham City is something that he has to
deal with kind of there and then on the
the terms of the city as he finds them
in addition to that Hugo Strange who's
the new warden of arkham city knows
Batman's true identity he knows that
Batman is Bruce Wayne and so the stakes
couldn't be higher for Batman that sense
of pressure and hostility was something
that we wanted to really throw at
players right up front because as Batman
once you then dominate in that context
the feeling of kind of power is just
overwhelming it's off the scale it's
great
batman arkham city coming to all three
platforms xbox 360 ps3 and pc in october
just it